[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in richard sherman
defensive back super bowl champ with the
seahawks he's got
something he's involved in fan
controlled football which we'll get to
in a moment how's morale today richard
oh fantastic yeah paradise
uh we had scottie miller on the
buccaneers wide receiver and he said
that he thinks he's the fastest wide
receiver
in the sport and that he was faster than
tyree kill
um if you had to put a week's pay on a
100-yard dash
who do you think is the fastest player
in the nfl
uh well
raheem mostert yep really no doubt
yeah there's no question now tyrique is
is quick and fast but like would you
rather
would you rather face the physical guy
let's say mike evans or tyree kill
um i mean it just depends on there i
guess
um there's no real preference you know
both both have
strengths and weaknesses both you know
um
are really good receivers so both
present issues but you know i don't
think there's one where i'm like man i
don't wanna
i definitely don't wanna face him you
know you just gotta find a way to get
stopped
what is that like when you um you're and
it probably doesn't happen very often
with you where you sneak a peek at the
quarterback and you know that guy is
he's going right by you and you gotta
turn and
you gotta run like hell i mean well
with most situations with a guy like
that i mean if you if you're gonna let
him get in your blind spot
he's he's gone he's gone you know
there's no no hey i gotta get on my
horse and i'm gonna catch up to him you
know you made a mistake
and um you know that mistake is gonna
cost you
would you uh rather face mahomes or
brady
uh um i mean like the same the same
it's the same situation with receivers i
mean both have strengths and weaknesses
um both are very difficult to to beat
um in the playoffs especially um
i played both in super bowl and we'd
also super bowl so
um you know no preference either way
you uh talked to chris collinsworth last
week and said uh that desean watson
should get out of houston
and go to the jets is do you think it's
salvageable at all in houston richard
um i think that's a question for deshawn
watson um
it doesn't seem that way you know it
seems like uh
the bridge is burned but you know you
gotta actually sean at this point
yeah i'm just wondering about that
because to me it's not a great situation
if they're not bringing in eric b enemy
or at least they didn't even interview
him to start with and then
they do it oh by the way to maybe keep
mahomes there but
uh yeah i just wonder they don't have
draft picks they got cap hell there
and uh still don't have still don't have
a head coach other than that
sounds like a great place to play um a
couple
right right yeah and i i understand i
i think desean needs to get out and uh i
i certainly understand his frustration
i just don't know if the jets is the
right situation over somebody like
miami well i mean miami would
would also but i just you know with
miami you got to say hey we're giving up
on the quarterback we just dropped the
top five
um we're giving up on him we're giving
you
you know multiple picks um
in this year's draft and next year craft
i i just i don't know i mean it'd be a
great fit
but i just don't know if miami wouldn't
give up all the grass capital
that will be required yesterday was the
uh
anniversary of kobe and uh his daughter
dying in that
helicopter crash i couldn't help but
think back when you had your
uh surgery your injury and and kobe
reached out to you
how did that did you know kobe was going
to call you
um no no i didn't i didn't you know we
had obviously been in communication
and developed a friendship um but i did
not think he'd be the first person to
call
um when i got my phone that day and um
it was really cool and in a special
moment for me
um you know and obviously the tragedy
last year was was
i mean still still dealing with um
the issues from that but uh i'm just
just sad for every
one on every one but you get that
phone number comes up i mean it doesn't
say kobe it just
comes up a phone number and then do you
just answer it
no no it's not called um i had a phone
number oh okay
yeah yeah yeah okay
tell me about the fan controlled
football uh what made you want to get in
uh
into this well i mean
they reached out a few years ago um
saying they had really cool concepts and
um
they were trying to execute it they were
like you know they kept saying it's kind
of like mad
like man but real life and like
well that's kind of crazy but i mean it
sounds like fans would love that
you know especially in this day and age
where technology and people want to have
more input and more effect on the game
i thought it'd be fantastic idea and i
still do
and
i think i lost you richard i think i
lost
tell richard thank you for joining us er
todd when you get back to him
but uh it's the uh fan controlled
football
and uh you got some names in here the
beast glacier boys wild aces
zappers johnny manziel's involved in
this as well
but uh tell richard thank you for the
phone call that wasn't a great
connection there to begin with